I do think we have a particular view I
mean people say the one percent I mean
I'd probably call it the 0. not one
percent and and that isn't just you know
Tech CEO bad guys it can also be people
like uh was it Dame Allison Rose you
know the the CEO of NatWest this is
really Daft you're talking about how
inclusive you are because you've
debunked on that Nigel farage you can't
even pay men and women the same are you
excited about a starma Premiership no I
think we need a political revolution in
this country and I don't I don't mean
like get out the bayonets and kill
everyone I think we need a profound
shift in power economic political
cultural away from London away from
Westminster towards Ordinary People I
saw Jarvis come to power and I saw
everyone on the left venerate each
others venerate socialism including
Corbin including people saying this is
an example of socialism working and now
everybody's moved on and they've moved
on to the next project and I guess my
question is to you seeing countries like
Venezuela seeing countries like the
Soviet Union how can you identify with
socialism when it's never worked
foreign
[Music]
ometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
Constantine and this is a show for you
if you want honest conversations with
Fascinating People our brilliant guest
today is an author journalist and the
founder of Navara media Aaron bastani
welcome to trigonometry my pleasure to
be here yeah we've been trying to get
you on for for a long time whenever
anyone wants to accuse us of being
right-wing what they say is why haven't
you had Aaron bastani on please tell
them it's not our fault we've been
trying to have you on for ages it's your
fault you're now officially left wing
yeah
the the home of the left exactly um we
prefer the term cut Sarah
we we had a tune for a few years ago
didn't win I I flaked on you guys if
that means you've got heat uh for being
you know politically partial or whatever
my apologies it was all on me but I'm
here now it's all water under the bridge
mate it's great to have you here tell
everybody a little bit about your
background who are you how are you where
you are what has been the journey
through life that leads you to be
sitting here talking to us so I have a
background in New Media and my
co-founder Navara media a bit like
yourselves a trigonometry
um
I started it more than a decade ago with
some people who've uh some have left the
picture some haven't
um and I was doing a PhD at the time and
then I had a time in my hands I had
resources
and as I was doing my PhD which was on
media to some extent two things became
really clear to me
firstly there was no going back to the
politics in the economy of pre-2008
something really had decisively shifted
in politics we weren't just going to go
back to Easy Street wages going up house
prices going up broadly people aren't
that you know
um critical of the political status quo
and at the same time it was it was
really obvious that people were
switching off Legacy Media that's only
gotten worse over time or gone better
over time the band how you see it that's
only intensified over time
but in the sort of 2013 2014 you know
with Scottish independence referendum
for instance
you don't have to support Independence
for Scotland to see some of that some of
the BBC stores were just extraordinary
extraordinary propaganda
um and Time After Time After Time I was
finding myself frustrated with the state
of political commentary political
journalism and obviously I had a set of
political commitments as my as my now
colleagues do and so we thought well
look here's a problem
and here's also potentially a solution
in that we we start our own Outlet which
is what we did and today
um we've just grown Beyond any
expectations I'm sure a similar story to
you guys right no man we had massive
expectations
you don't think like I think last month
on Instagram we reached 12 13 million
people it's amazing yeah we're reaching
you know lots of people on on YouTube
like yourselves
um lots of people with podcasts we do
articles as well some of them are really
we've broken some interesting stories
you know and we brought the label X
story
um I don't think we expected that all to
happen I think that's partly because the
talent of my colleagues were brilliant
and also partly because the Legacy Media
is just so bad at their job that people
are craving something different well
that's something we can easily agree and
I think and that's actually what I was
going to ask you you were ahead of the
curve in terms of us we started this in
April 2018 you would have started in
2013. you said 10 years ago yeah so we
had a podcast well it wasn't even a
podcast it was a radio show on a
community radio station in London called
resonance FM so we were actually going
out on an FM frequency with a weekly
show but we didn't have a podcast with a
website until 2013 yeah right and so
what was the moment for you when you
realized the mainstream media I just
they're not doing a good job of
Journalism anymore because I can tell
you what for a lot of people who are
sort of heterodoc Center where I see us
and right-leaning people too one of the
key moments was Jordan Peterson being
interviewed by Kathy Newman I don't know
if you remember that yeah of course and
a lot of people just went wait this
isn't this is fake this isn't a
conversation this isn't how people talk
if you had a a psychology professor in
your living room that you may disagree
with that's not how you would talk to
them and if you did talk to them like
that you'd think this person's demented
right was there a moment like that for
you coming from a left-wing perspective
where you were just like I saw that and
I was like okay there's no going back
for the mainstream anymore there's so
many I mean it happens every week
doesn't it I think for me one of the wow
moments was I think at the time Andrew
Mar was the BBC political editor and he
wrote a novel
which I find quite strange you shouldn't
really have times around novel when
you're running hundreds of thousands of
pounds paid by the BBC but anyway maybe
I'm being mean and the um the launch
party for that novel can you guess where
it was
number 10 Downing Street and so you
think your job is to scrutinize these
people they're doing you a favor to
launch your novel and I just thought
you're not serious like I don't you
shouldn't be hectoring them and being
angry with them but there should be a
slight free source like tension between
politicians and political journalists
there's just a bit wary of that guy be
careful don't you know don't be too
loose-lipped that's a that's healthy for
democracy and when I saw that story I
thought
the BBC's buggered and I think more
broadly the the relationship between
politicians and the media in this
country is bucketing is it is so
unhealthy and I think it's worse in the
US because in this country everything's
in London
everything's in London whereas in the US
you've got your politicians in
Washington you've got your La people
your Texas people your New York people
it's here it's so bad it isn't it it's a
very profound Point here it is bad
was there a moment for you where you
realize that left-wing media wasn't
everything it purported to be where you
looked at certain Outlets I mean maybe
it's the guardian maybe it's others
where you thought hang on a minute this
isn't what I associate with the left or
left-wing media well there's not that
much left-wing media in the UK so I mean
I'd start with set the Daily Mirror it's
been a labor sporting paper for a very
long time
you know I
don't know I remember doing um BBC any
questions and I mentioned a story and
then you know these are this is Middle
England right I was somewhere in like
Yeovil or something you know lib Dem
Tory floating voters this isn't middle
England and I said oh the story is from
The Daily Mirror they'll start laughing
at me right rightly so because for them
it's just it's a tabloid you know I
don't think it has necessary a sort of
political take on things you know it's a
spin on
you know it's like the Sun but the other
side I don't think it's quite as bad
yeah you know it's that's the ballpark
the garden I think is a liberal paper
rather than a left paper but you know we
can park that for a moment what I would
say is the guardian
has really regressed so 10 years ago it
had The Bravery to do the Snowden stuff
it had the brave Ridge to the wikileak
stuff that would not happen now that
would really why not I think editorial
choices would just say I just don't
think it would happen I think well
definitely with Wikileaks Snowden I
don't know with um with Wikileaks and
the Glenn Greenwood staff I think you
know it's easy to say oh Alan rusbridge
is gone kathlein is the editor now they
wouldn't do that but I just feel like
there's not the same intellectual
curiosity they used to be at the
guardian in 15 years ago
um and I I I can't quite you know I
would buy the guardian 15 years ago I
wouldn't buy it I wouldn't pay for it
now you know I have a subscription for
the Ft I I read the ft and it's full of
facts and dates and I'll disagree with
all the columnists but it's useful high
value information I'm sorry to say the
guardian isn't that you know and do you
think part of the problem is identity
politics and writing through always to
the prism of race and gender and that's
not to say that that doesn't have Merit
occasionally but that then means that
you just ignore the the sheer facts of
the situation what is happening on the
ground
the problem is I don't really read the
garden yeah so I don't know but you know
I I agree with your point here so for
instance there's something really
irritates me which is
um
your ex this person's why therefore this
person is the only person that can have
valid opinions on issues relating to why
people that can be with us to raise
gender Etc so for instance I'm half
Iranian I might say
um I'm uh I think the process in Iran
um are bad I don't think they're bad
before you know I might say they're bad
I might say something which is quite
controversial right
um at which point
um you know you might say somebody's not
a relationship like I disagree they seem
quite good you know it's about women's
Liberation civil liberties they seem
very positive I would say you can't have
a legitimate view on this because you
you're not Iranian well somewhere in the
middle of all this are the facts and the
truth and values which don't really they
aren't contingent on on who you are your
identity and so on so on that point I I
agree with you is it a problem really
for the for the guardian it's a hard one
to say I mean I just don't read their
columns
that much I I think actually it's worse
than that in a way because this stuff is
percolated
a whole layer of the media and you can
find it in ad campaigns you can find it
in the guardian you might even find it
in in sort of censor sensor right
newspapers sometimes yeah um for sure so
I think it's I think it's a bit bigger
than that actually yeah well our whole
society is infested with this idea
actually that we should look at
everything through the through the prism
of well you can't speak about this
because you're not that thing I agree I
was curious you mentioned there's no not
much left-wing media in the UK would you
do are you one of the people on the left
who feels that the BBC is Right leaning
no I think I think the BBC is liberal
right so what do I mean by that it's
it's socially liberal and has a social
liberal agenda absolutely it was
absolutely opposed to brexit I say that
somebody voted remain it was opposed to
brexit
um and it's also economically liberal so
I think it's very
um
um what's the word
circumspect about radical economic ideas
particularly from the left but actually
I think any kind of radical chroma code
is anybody who's saying there's a
problem let's try this solution an
actual solution oriented sort of mode of
thinking just doesn't sit well with them
um so I think lots of people from the
left dislike the BBC because they see
the fact it's economically liberal then
lots of people from the right see the
BBC and they say well it's socially
liberal and so I I can see both points
of view but it is and because we don't
have a successful Liberal Party in this
country anymore which we did until the
early 20th century it is very much a
continuation of that sort of patrician
liberalism which was the liberal party
you know um which broadly speaking after
it collapsed kind of becomes a faction
within both labor and the Tories so I
the the BBC has kind of progressive
moments and I'm sure it has it has like
journalists who are on the left for sure
but I would say it's a liberal a liberal
news organizer so explain that to us
because those words liberal and left get
used very differently uh by different
people and they also get used very
differently in the United States versus
the UK like a liberal in America is a
left-winger basically right although
there's increasing conversation about
Classical liberalism and that is a
different thing entirely when you say
the BBC is a liberal institution and
you're positioning that as a different
thing to you which is left wing explain
that to people what do you mean what's
the difference how how are these things
different
so a really a really great way of
explaining this I think is the fact that
BBC I think it's changed now but they
didn't have an industrial relations
correspondent they didn't have a labor
correspondent so they or or editor
rather than had a correspondent didn't
have a labor editor which they would
have had all the way through really to
the 1980s which is somebody whose job is
to say
these workers are getting screwed here a
thousand people have just been laid off
here a lot of the piano story for
instance right
um these people have gone on strike
they've got a big pay rise uh these
women are campaigning for better
maternity uh leave conditions at work
etc
BBC doesn't focus on that stuff now
someone who's on the left I care about
that stuff right I care deeply about
that stuff instead the BBC will focus on
like
as a liberal organization
representation
um uh more women in boardrooms right I'm
not saying more winning boardrooms is
bad although it is I'm not saying it's
bad yeah but that affects a tiny Slither
of society yeah meanwhile you're not
talking about women organizing in their
workplaces for better maternity care
policies for instance yeah so that makes
perfect sense and I remember during the
hole in cozy Fulani Affair it was
covered like it was a terrorist attack
when you sort of think there's probably
much bigger core issues affecting way
more people which I think is what you're
talking so is your focus basically an
old school class-based approach where
you were like well the workers who are
the majority of the society they're at
the bottom they're not getting paid
enough they're not treated well by their
employers that's who I'm advocating for
is that broadly speaking the angle yes I
won't say that at the bottom I would say
we we are interested in the stories of
working people
um and that's another politician's arms
but frankly you know the middle class
and the working class in this country
we just did a show on this actually with
a great guy Dan Evans you know we talked
about the petty Bourgeois what does it
mean you know my dad's a taxi driver he
he categorized in his Petty Bourgeois
right lots of people with their own
shops or small businesses they work
harder than the most exploited workers
it's a different relationship right
because of course they get the dividends
the profit and one day they might be
very rich as a result but they work
incredibly hard on these people like
literally exhausting themselves and
killing themselves
um in terms of what we do like I said
it's about working people
um
I do think though in some of you said
old school sort of socialist way I do
think we have a particular view I mean
people say the one percent I mean I'd
probably call it the 0.01 you know the
the the economic Elite frankly who are
pro privatization with regards to things
like water
um who fundamentally don't think
democracy matters
um who contrives sort of Mickey Mouse
but sort of bizarre issues so that we
don't actually confront the real
problems in society and and that isn't
just you know Tech CEO bad guys it can
also be people like uh was it Dame
Allison Rose you know the the CEO of
NatWest you know NatWest have all these
quote unquote Progressive inclusive
policies
and yet I think the the gender pay Gap
in the organization wasn't like 30 right
like this is really Daft you're talking
about how inclusive you are because
you've debunked in that Nigel farage you
can't even pay men and women the same so
um for doing the same job so you know
this Elites also in a way mirrors what I
was saying about the BBC
generally speaking it's actually more
sociable than we think so people on the
right will say this Elite is socially
liberal they're all lefties I'm on the
left saying they're also economically
liberal and they're exploiting you know
the rest of society we're probably
we're both right in a way do you ever
get frustrated how the left is
mischaracterized because
I'm not on the left as a whole there's
certain aspects of the left I'm very
sympathetic too but I see people on the
right going oh let's do think like this
and you go no they don't and if you if
somebody said the inverse you'd get
upset with them so how is it fair to say
all left are pro-romain liberals and you
go well you you're overlooking lexit for
example oh cool let's be real corbyn was
pro-brexit you know of course I was
thinking about this it wasn't very
honest well I I think he's a Democrat so
I think you know he was the party leader
I think he did what he thought was right
I don't think he secretly you know
there's conspiracy secretly Around The
Ballot Box and wrote to leave I won't
give up I mean maybe he did I don't
think he went that far though
um but there is a sort of weird
alternative reality where
um
Jeremy corbyn isn't the labor leader in
2016. somebody else is uh labor sort of
um lose the election brexit but label is
a referendum rather because they would
have been campaigning for remain and
Jeremy corbyn is like elevated it's like
this cult hero because you know him and
farage secured you know there's this and
also what I found really funny is in
that scenario he would also be expelled
from the labor party yeah you know he
ends up in a similar place so
um no not all left-wing people feel the
same this is the great thing with um
with the rmt and the and the strikes
we've had you know Mick Lynch who's
their their their their their Chief the
the rail Workers Union I think it's so
useful for the average sort of Joe blogs
you know member of the public to see a
guy you know who's you know bald late
50s early 60s a Gruff uh the millwall
fan yeah and he's left wing and I think
that's so good for a number of things I
think it's good for left because it
undoes a few character caricatures but I
also think it's just so healthy for for
our society you know you can't presume
somebody's politics just by how they
look like that's a really you know it's
a really bigoted thing to do actually
yeah
um yeah it may look like a Gammon is
what Aaron's saying you don't know that
he is yeah and and that is a profound
point because
in 2016 and post 2016 that term Gammon
would have been used for people like
Mick lyncher and Eddie Dempsey who I
would have seen as the fulcrum of the
left the people who the the what I think
left-wing means which is people coming
out representing workers trying to get
them a better deal and what I've seen on
the left now and look maybe it's Twitter
amplifying these voices you know
somebody going you know if you're fat
phobic you're Hitler
and I go did you actually see that
pretty much you may be exaggerating yeah
exaggerating at times I got no what do
we mean yeah
yeah internet insanity
well I think I think fat phobia is I
think it's bad to discriminate against
somebody because of how they look yeah
to bully them on that basis but I don't
think that makes I fat shamed him for
two years look how slim he looks I don't
think I don't think that makes you look
like well I'm older now I'm 39 but I
mean I was I was quite ripped until
about 30 and that was definitely because
of my dad's body shaming when I was
about nine so I sort of got into
bodybuilding and you know Athletics and
whatnot but on a serious note
um
it's that left wing I mean I look there
are lots of things which are right wing
there are lots of things which
conservatives there are conservatives
out there that want to pull down all the
trees and build loads of skyscrapers and
you know Chase GDP relentlessly there
are also conservatives out there who
want to reintroduce beaver and you know
uh rewild things and introduce
regenerative farming and I think in a
very strange way they both sit in the
same tradition I think you have to be
realistic on the left you know that that
those arguments are on the left because
they're they're taking aim at a form of
Oppression or antagonism or or hatred's
a strong word but you know what I mean
and so I think they probably are on the
left
um I I don't agree with that proposition
though
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country would
judge Men's Health by his ability to
wrestle bear in London I have since
found out this has very different
meaning we've all had a knight that's
got out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my ancestors well if
you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Foods sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we used it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we heard hugely successful trip it is
very economical and I felt strong enough
to wrestle America which we all know is
grotosely weak compared to Great Russian
Bear if you're looking for a simpler and
cost effective supplement routine ag1 is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try edgy1 and get five free agu1
travel packs and a free one-year supply
of vitamin D with your first purchase go
to drink ag1.com trigonometry that's
drink ag1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like me
so the left is a very broad Coalition so
what can labor do in kierstama do to
hold together this very broad Coalition
of people who are actually
think and believe very very different
things somebody who is a left-wing
Progressive I mean it's a cliche in
Islington is going to think very
differently to an old school former
Miner in a town like Darlington
it's a great question I mean the thing
is labor a lot of people say Tony
Blair's Labor's most successful prime
minister actually it's Harold was the
one for elections and in the 60s laid
about the exact same problem they kept
on winning you know they went in what 60
64 66 74 I think 76 you know so they
they won repeatedly with their economic
base being you know organized labor but
also introducing things like um the
rights divorce abortion
um decriminalizing homosexuality so very
socially liberal agenda and and they
made that work so I think you know it
it's not impossible you can do it I
think you just need to be open with the
electorate about it you know I I
increasingly find myself drawn to the
green party I like the greens
I'm pro-nuclear right I'm Pro hs2
I'm Pro uh what else is I was going for
you're drawn to the greens they're not
drawn to you yeah exactly but I like a
lot of what they stand for I like their
values I just think they're wrong about
some really big issues yeah oh I'll vote
low for the next election but I think if
I was in Bristol West for instance where
they have a good chance of winning I
would vote for the grades
um you know I think I think most of the
electorates adult enough actually to
vote on I think that's what happened in
2017 right I think lots of people don't
like Jeremy corbyn they say I actually
quite like three or four of those
policies and I'll plump for labor I
think by 2019 the Avalanche was so
strong the media campaign the unforced
Errors By the labor leadership brexit it
was too much to hold back but I think
most the electorate sensible enough to
go these two or three things really
matter to me I think they'll do a better
job than the other lot on those two or
three things I'll ask you the same
question that I've asked we've had a
bunch of left Wingers on the show in the
short succession actually but
um
it seems to me that Starman and labor
party are going to win the next election
look anything can happen between now and
then but it's looking that way are you
excited about a starma Premiership
no why not no I'm not well I I was asked
the evil Tories are going to be out
isn't that a good thing evil tourism
yeah yeah great I mean what's
interesting is that um
Boris Johnson 2019
at the moment
on for instance climate change
was to the left of case diamond right
now he was it's very hard for people for
the not even the Twitter left I like the
Twitter and I'm on the Twitter left the
sort of big liberal accounts on social
media you like most of my tweets no
that's true well I'm a hatch blocks
thinker I think that's how the new
Statesman to described me yeah all over
the place is how normal people would
describe it
um
you know that the nasty Tories have to
go they're all full blah blah blah well
Boris Johnson was funding ltns right
um which you know they'd want they want
to disown that now low traffic
neighborhoods yeah they want to disown
that now they had very ambitious um
commitments on on decarbonisation they
moved huge numbers of public sector jobs
for instance to Darlington brilliant
great I'm really happy about that I mean
the public sector workers weren't but
yeah
it's got it's got its attractions yeah
and you know I I feel like that there's
just this is the most right-wing
government in history it's like on the
political economy side it really isn't
like there's a few you know sometimes
you'll hear something crazy and you know
that they release as a as a press
release or as a media message but on the
on the sort of fundamentals Boris
Johnson was to the left of David Cameron
these same people had no problem with
David Cameron right and austerity
between 2010 and 2016 in terms of how
you know how it dismantled lots of
really cool parts of how you know this
country functions
um so yes the Tories will be gone I
think that's good my view is that labor
will be less bad
which is obviously not great and it's
probably why people aren't sort of you
know
infused about a starma Premiership but
equally I think that's probably why he's
going to win over lots of floating lib
demitory voters or floating lib Dem
labor voters or Tory labor voters in the
red wall I think they'll be less bad but
fundamentally I think we need a I think
we need a political revolution in this
country and I don't I don't mean like
get out the bayonets and kill everyone I
think we need a profound shift in power
economic political cultural away from
London away from Westminster towards
Ordinary People a few ways of doing that
for representation I think electoral
reform of some kind and I think you need
to start dismantling some of the really
dysfunctional parts of British politics
well for instance the electoral system
is the first one for me
um and this is going to sound sort of
strange the worst part for me of first
pass the post isn't the two-party system
it's the liberal Democrats because the
liberal Democrats in tourist seats will
say to labor voters we're the only ones
that commit the Tories you have to vote
for us then
um you know they'll go in labor seats
say the Tory voters we're the only ones
that can meet labor right they have
actual no substantial politics they're
purely a consequence of
the two-part system when we're not you
know we're not um that bad and if you
don't like these guys these other guys
companies like how the hell is that
basis for a democratic vote so I I just
think when you look at the Tories you
look at Labor you look at the lib Dems
so much as dysfunction with first pass
the post that that would be the first
one for me I think I mean one we've had
plenty of people on to talk about uh the
problems with first past the post and
and what a proportional system might
mean one of the things it will likely
mean is that
um extremist parties do very well
and so I sometimes and I'm very open to
the idea of PR but I think I wonder
whether people have thought about that
but look I actually you've raised a a
few points that I think are bigger than
this whole Twitter Left Right [__]
that we've spent too much time talking
about
um and I want to talk to you about a
couple of things where we may agree less
than we have done so far one of them is
and I'm glad you said the no point no no
one percent but this narrative generally
worries me because people talk about the
one percent or the top this or the top
that and I look at the statistics the
top 10 of people in this country pay 60
of all the income tax right and I sort
of think like I mean okay they're rich
and we're British so we have to slag off
people who've done well it's kind of
part of our culture
but are they really the bad guys the
people who are earning what what would
be put in top 10 are probably like over
80 grand a year they are they really the
bad ones that we have to point our
fingers at and go you're not paying
enough tax when they're 10 are providing
60 of the income do you know what I mean
no I totally agree I mean Labor's
Manifesto in
2019 was they would increase tax on the
top five percent so even that I I agree
with you there could be somebody look on
80 grand a year
um they've got a couple of kids uh maybe
the other half whether it's the wife or
the husband maybe just works part-time
for whatever reason partly because
caring for kids or whatever you know
given what's just happened mortgage
rates energy they might think I need to
put some away to look after my parents a
few years
my own pension you know it doesn't go
that far so I agree they're not the
enemy but you know there was an amazing
quote recently from the Imagine director
of Harrods and this was in like the
midst of the sort of Crisis you know
with living standards
and they said we're doing great you know
uh recessions and economic downturns uh
the rich always get rich when a
recession that's what they said and I
think that is a problem I think that is
a problem I think it's a problem that in
the European Union
and we're not in their opinion in Europe
the most valuable company is lvmh Louis
Vuitton Moe Hennessy it's a luxury goods
brand the biggest companies in the
United States are producing
extraordinary goods and services for
literally billions of people we're
making designer handbags and champagne
there's nothing wrong with that but I
think it says something quite
significant about
how our economies work and also is that
really the basis of like future
Prosperity I suspect it's not no
probably not but I guess what I'm asking
you more about is this I hear this a lot
and I'm not talking about Twitter I'm
talking about question time I'm talking
about mainstream Flagship programs
people always talk I'm not in the one
percent I may never be in the one
percent but the more I meet people who
are the more I realize that look of
course this country has a history of the
land of gentry right people who don't
whose only achievement as they went to
Eaton in the Seventh Generation yeah
I've met those people and they're
annoying admittedly but there's like
there's not a lot of them most of the
people I meet who are wealthy and who
have a high income are people who've
created things that are of value to
other people right they are actually
creating jobs they're creating
opportunities so when I see them being
sort of demonized as the problem I don't
really know that that to me is accurate
because I'm not envious of them I'm like
you've done well because you've
contributed to other people's lives
you've created opportunities for other
people you've created a product that
other people want to buy or a service or
whatever and I I'm quite uncomfortable
with that rhetoric do you know what I
mean well I sort of disagree so like
look at landlords we have a lot of
landlords yeah right a lot so it's not
even the one percent like you said yeah
yeah it's like over two million yeah
yeah and it's lots of people that would
be electricians or Tradesmen and they
didn't punish insurance and that's their
pension right yeah so they're not like
you know they're exploiting arguably
their tenants but they're not like you
know they're this caricature of the one
percent absolutely but the way I see it
is this
all the capital that's going into buy to
lets all the Intel these are very smart
people right
um all the construction work and the and
the application that goes into building
these little rabbit hutches for people I
just think and then you look at the High
Street and you think surely it would
make more sense to society you want to
make money like you say you've been
making money from selling goods and
services to people
um starting a business and I think too
much of the money and capital and the
know-how and the ambition has gone for
instance in the vital that's in this
country this is where you and I would
and Francis would agree completely that
the housing market is completely [__]
on purpose and they refuse to fix it
yeah right because the incentive
structure rewards all the behavior
that's there but that's a different
issue to the one percent because as you
say most of the buy to lets are just
owned by people who built up some
capital in in their housing and then
bought another flat when they could or
whatever and rent it out and I agree
with the housing market is a big problem
that needs fixing but that isn't my
point my point is are the people at the
top the captains of industry let's say
the people who started a big business
even if the captains of industry don't
often don't start businesses anymore
maybe maybe but I know people who do
just what I'm saying right people who
run big businesses let's say it doesn't
really matter they are creating value
for the rest of us one way or another
why are they a problem and I'm open to
the possibility that they are I'm just
saying why why is there this narrative
and maybe I'm holding the wrong person
to to account here maybe you don't think
that I don't know do you see what I'm
getting at the housing market is a real
issue but if we set that aside why is
creating wealth and earning a high
income a problem
I don't think it is I mean as long as
you know there's a great line by
clementley and I think he was sort of
criticizing charity he said you know a
patriot would just pay their taxes and
that would be done you know I think
Charities are called
I can't remember a cold Dreadful thing
something like that and I you know look
if you are willing to work hard and and
like you say you meet these people
almost all of them say I've been very
lucky right people have done really
spectacular things in business whatever
they go I worked hard I'm smart blah
blah blah I was also really lucky right
place right time maybe it would have
happened at a different time you know if
it hadn't happened then but generally
speaking I was very lucky and there's a
lot of gratitude there but um let's pick
one issue corporation tax
um corporation tax
you need to be competitive obviously we
have higher rates of corporation tax in
places like Japan or California or
Germany than we do here now the argument
would be
don't Corporation taxes attacks on
corporate profits to start with if
you're not making any profits you're not
taxed on the argument would be oh the
lower the rate of corporation tax
the highly incentive to select
businesses right what actually what we
know empirically is that a higher
corporation tax not too high because yes
they will go but a higher rate of
corporation tax means that businesses
reinvest in fixed Capital robotics
upskilling workers because they don't
want to pay tax right they'd rather
reinvest it in the business and give it
to hmrc and and so there's a very
sensible pro-business argument for
higher corporation tax not 60 70 percent
but you know somewhere close to Germany
and in the last election again labor was
saying let's get 20 26 and that's still
lower than the places I just mentioned
and I think if you want a high
productivity smart economy
um
but then I think you'd have to do
something like that it doesn't mean I
hate rich people or I think profits are
bad it's about like say aligning the
incentives to create a more affluent
prosperous country if you look at for
instance these they're a remarkable
tables on this industrial robots per
head you know Britain is the country
that gave the world the national
Revolution we're nowhere we're like
we're below like Thailand right we have
a very very low automation economy in
this country so it should be a question
of like public policy interest how do we
change that I think one answer is
probably corporation tax I mean given
given the dust spin the country's in
right now maybe not but in in India
countries do have to make a profit to
pay dividends to attract investors yeah
so there's a trade-off of course no
there is a trade-off but I think it
should be part of a policy mix and and
if people disagree they need to explain
why I think something like corporation
tax for too long has been like you're
jealous of rich people I'm sure some
people that's not what I'm saying yeah
I'm hearing a lot of this talk about the
one percent and look I think it's fair
to say and this isn't me trying to
attack the left in any way please is
fair to say that a lot of people vocal
people on the left do hate rich people I
I see that when I see the way they talk
about it now you you clearly don't
but why it's a strong one isn't it isn't
it hating them yeah oh yeah yeah there
is I know I'm not just I'm not saying I
don't exist but can you give me an
example obviously I actually can't
because I'm not thinking of a specific
moment but I hear this over and over and
as I say I'm not talking about Twitter
or X or whatever it's called now I'm
talking about big discussion shows where
it's like the rich the rich the rich and
I I don't I've never seen the rich as
bad people in and of themselves no you
know
um but it sounds like you don't either
well look comp let's go to our the OG
Karl Marx you know he would say he would
say that
um in a way capitalists are in a way
they are in a
in a desperate situation
because it's capitalists are in
competition with one other right and
this is the beauty of capitalism you're
in competition with one another you have
to produce the best goods and services
at the best price to get market share
if you don't you're screwed your
opponent gets not your you know your
rival gets market share this is great
for the customer if you're you know this
is sort of neoliberal or the liberal
classical Economist read on things what
Mark says is a really important Insight
is they're in competition with each
other and this makes them permanently
anxious because of course if you fail
the worst thing of all happens you join
the working class so and you have to do
certain things so for instance right
that sounds terrifying if you if you own
a business and you're selling X product
at 10 pounds and your rival is selling
it for nine pounds you have to sell it
for nine pounds otherwise you're gone so
what does that mean ideally you know you
find new ways of increasing productivity
which don't hurt anybody but the first
Port of cool for many is okay cut ahead
count cut quality
um reduce pay
um you know get rid of this benefit so
and that might that might not be because
they're a bad person they have to do it
because capitalism is inherently a
competitive system an Amazon sorry for
instance no no it's cool it's cool um
Amazon would be very good example of
this I mean we had James Bloodworth on
to talk about his book which exposed a
lot of the practices that these giant
multinational corporations are engaging
in to drive down their costs and and by
the way you talk about the High Street
that's why the High Street is [__]
it's not because people aren't investing
in it it's because they can't compete
with Amazon
um so I I hear you I was just curious
because I just I wonder how we have a
productive economy if if there is a
section of the population who sees
anyone who's made any money as a problem
you know and sort of sometimes feels
like that to me but anyway yeah so yeah
so I mean
is the issue I think the problem is is
that people talk about the rich and they
conflate the Amazons and the Jeff Bezos
of this world with the bloke who's maybe
a very successful estate agent on 90k a
year do you think that is he is an
estate agent yeah yeah so you're right
to hate them it's a good point I think
there's I think there's an interesting
angle here which is obviously we're in
the anglophone world right we speak
English yeah and
um what's the Great Line you know uh the
United States and Britain are separated
by the same language you know two
countries divided by a Common Language
exactly yeah very well put that's
exactly it
um and I think a lot of this comes from
the US
where it's entirely legitimate right
yeah where you have a country which with
tens of millions of people that don't
have access necessarily to health care
where the working class Blue Collar
works in the US have been screwed
frankly let's be real for 20 25 years
and where there is a runaway
plutocratically they are earning huge
amounts of money
um not even earning the market caps of
their businesses are skyrocketing and
they obviously own lots of that so yeah
Bezos mask you know when I was growing
up
the idea of a company being worth a
trillion dollars
was like well well that probably never
happened you know I think Apple now is
touching three trillion dollars
um and some of the business practices
which underpin that yes apples sell
amazing products I've got an iPhone here
I have an iMac but there's also lots of
you could say Shady stuff right share
BuyBacks they're inflating the price of
their stock that makes the people like
Tim Cook for instance better off
um Elon Musk with Tesla I think he's
done an amazing thing with Tesla people
love the bachelor mask meet included I
think he's probably I think he's maybe
screwed to it so we'll see you know he's
defied predictions before he accelerated
um the adoption of electric vehicles
probably by about 15 20 years like an
incredible thing to do he took on like
the major car manufacturers and he's
done really well like incredible thing
to do
but there's a few what economists would
call negative externalities with this if
you're worth 200 billion you know the
amount of political power you can buy
with 200 billion is incredibly dangerous
that to me is the is the main thing so
yes it's bad that these people have so
much money but it's what they can buy
with that money in terms of political
influence the media opinion making so
the if the Koch brothers were just
billionaires fine but it's the fact that
they are trying to buy massive political
influence in in a range of areas they're
trying to really they've tried to
basically buy candidates in the past so
I I think for much of the left the big
problem is political capture by the
elite as much as those people being rich
if they were just rich and they sort of
just you know did their thing and
enjoyed life I think we'd be having a
slightly different debate but you know
Jeff Bezos has the Washington Post and
then the Washington Post runs something
excoriating Donald Trump I can see why
the average American voters would say
this is kind of screwed up actually oh I
completely agree with you and it's a
very good point my issue always with the
left is it's a very personal thing to me
so my background everyone's got a gonna
drink because you know it's the it's the
end joke so my mother's from Venezuela I
I saw Jarvis come to power in 99 I saw
him bring socialism as we would say to
the country
I saw him shut down journalists uh he
put one of my relatives under house
arrest because
he refused to
enact Travis's wishes which would make
the country poorer and he was put under
house arrest until he complied I saw
Chavez threatened journalists until the
point my cousin had to leave because he
didn't know at one o'clock in the
morning there was going to be a knock on
the door and he was going to a prison
called La Dumba I mean I don't need to
explain what that is and I saw everyone
on the left venerate Chavez venerate
socialism including Corbin including
people saying this is an example of
socialism working
and that was the moment for me where
I've fell out of love with the left
because I was trying to say hang on this
isn't
what you think it is but people didn't
care and now everybody's moved on and
they've moved on to the next project and
saying they're socialists and everyone
in my country
is screwed to be honest with you
and I guess my question is to you seeing
countries like Venezuela seeing
countries like the Soviet Union how can
we how can you identify with socialism
when it's never worked
well that's an interesting one let's
start with Venezuela so I think I think
South America is incredibly unique yeah
because because of the Monroe Doctrine
because of the fact that you have this
Global superpower to your North yep the
United States never let social democracy
happen in South America it was not
allowed this happens in Guatemala with a
guy called our Benz in the 1950s he
really just wants to Institute a bit of
land reform and Trade union rights
really nothing radical nothing that
wasn't happening in by Social Democratic
parties in Europe the point was that
wasn't allowed that was not allowed so
this idea of well if only the South
Americans could have sort of mainstream
center-left politicians and they tried
it okay they were removed by military
coups and interestingly enough who was
in Guatemala in the 50s when it happened
Che Guevara yeah and he says well
they're not going to let us do that then
we've got to seize control by you know
by military means and actually we're
going to have to hold on to power in a
very different way so I think the
development of socialism in South
America it's not to make excuses for
anyone but I think the development of
socialism in South America is quite
unique and quite particular because
parliamentary Democratic Socialism or
social democracy like we have in Europe
was not allowed it was completely off
the table
um so that's parking that one and in
terms of socialism not working I suppose
and again I also wouldn't compare the
Soviet Union to Venezuela yeah I I think
Venezuela under Chavez did well because
of higher oil prices so there was a
sense of of rising Prosperity uh and
obviously when oil prices went down that
sort of disappeared again I think with
the Soviet Union it was it was different
in so much as there was there was a
national project of of industrialization
too quickly but there was a different
kind of project it was reaching towards
a modernity in a different kind of way
to somewhere like Venezuela I feel I
might be wrong
um and it and the Russian people and the
peoples of of the former Soviet Union I
think can be proud of certain
accomplishments such as the first person
in space and it's incredible
technological achievement I think it's
an amazing achievement the defeat of
Nazism I think should be very proud of
that
um and there wasn't so much a
technological achievement but yeah yeah
well no but you know you say that but um
there's some really interesting stuff
about this about the ability of the
Soviet Union after 1940-41 to actually
start developing incredible tanks
incredible military technology
incredible but it could rival the
Germans there's a well in a way that
nobody predicts you know what actually
it's the other way around interestingly
so the Soviet Union people don't know
this because the Soviets got overrun in
in 41 and early 42. what actually
happened is the Soviets had far superior
technology in the early period but then
they got outpaced by the German uh
military machine as the war went on so
by the end of the war uh what the kind
of Technology the Germans had is the
basis of all our technology now they had
cruise missiles basically in their
Etc what and there's a reason the
Soviets lost 20 million people of course
World War II
um but you I mean look your point look
every society has positives in every way
of structuring it I guess the point that
uh Francis is making about it not
working is in the Soviet Union and in
Venezuela
the argument would be about socialism
that it is a way of thinking about the
world that is so unnatural to human
beings the way that we evolve to think
about our own interests and the
interests of others in the Soviet Union
as you know the idea was that you were
supposed to put the needs of the state
above the those of your own family that
it takes putting people in latumba or it
takes people in wouldn't being put into
gulags to achieve that dream in which
Pavlik marozov gives up his parents to
the state uh because it's such an
unnatural way that doesn't really apply
onto how human beings are white if we
were mole rats or ants where we were
genetically linked uh that might be
easier to do do you see what that that's
kind of more the argument no I think
that's and I think the 20th century has
a series of experiments like this from
Nazi Germany to the USSR to the Khmer
Rouge where you have this incredibly I
mean I don't even think
economic projects in extremely
cultural projects an extremely
Innovative as cultural projects I like
the idea that a human being is a tabula
rasa black slay and look I I don't
I don't think that's necessarily doesn't
have to be Socialism or fascism or
anything like that I think it has a
certain interpretation of human nature
which was we now know is wrong we know
that doesn't function so why am I a
socialist I would actually I'm a Marxist
frankly and we'll get well I can also go
back to a few what I would call success
stories regarding Democratic socialism
we'll pilot for a moment I'm a socialist
because I believe that workers generally
should be as uh close to the the product
of the labor as possible they should
have as little of it alienated from them
as possible which means a fair deal for
workers right so if a worker is creating
value per hour of 30 pounds an hour I
think they should be earning a
significant chunk of that clearly there
should be a little bit of profit there
should be some taxes and so on and so
forth but the idea that a worker should
be exploited from the products of the
labor I think is is a moral affront and
I think that to me I'm a Catholic but
that to me it's almost like that's
almost like an article of faith I think
a good society allows workers to enjoy a
significant share of the value that they
create
um in terms of Marxism I'm a Marxist the
capital
um Das Capital isn't um uh is not a
Manifesto he doesn't Manifesto called
The Communist Manifesto but capital is
called capital A critique of political
economy so what what he does in
capitalists he's critiquing the
classical political economists JS mail
Adam Smith Ricardo and whatnot and I
know this is pretty quite cliched for
many people and clearly that's not what
happens in the 20th century but Marx
wasn't a programmatic thinker he has
some some some parts where he says you
may need to do this this or this or he
talks about you know Civil War in France
the military Theory and whatnot but the
stuff that you see in the Soviet Union
or with the Khmer Rouge
is as connected to what Marx is talking
about as say Nazi Germany is with Edmund
buck that's my that's my view you know
it's like saying how could you be a
conservative because of look look where
it ends up when you believe in flag
family uh tradition yeah and tradition
and you know patriotism is very muscular
robustness look where it ends up look
there's been many decent people who
believe in all those things who never
ended up in that place so I I try to
have a bit more of a nuanced View and
then in terms of where it sort of
succeeded you know look at Singapore Lee
kuang Yoo would have identified as
Democratic Socialist look he's very you
know he's very controversial figure but
Singapore and the state had a very
distinct role in its development really
from the 1950s all the way through to
today today it's one of the wealthiest
countries in the world has no natural
resources
um basically people thought uh it
wouldn't last 10 minutes once the
British left I think in the early 1970s
they built an incredibly complex
sophisticated High productivity economy
how do they do that Central planning
um they promoted people on the base of
competence and talent and they didn't
allow uh you know free market to run
right and so much as
um
having an unplanned economy there was a
you know let the uh the Invisible Hand
do its thing they didn't do that that a
significant amount of planning and they
wanted that planning to create wealth
which would
um would lead to more prosperous country
and it worked now I'm not saying
Singapore is a socialist Paradise but on
things like for instance land actually
how land policy Works in Singapore this
effectively a socialist policy so you
know I I think it's hard to say well
where has it worked we've got very clear
identifiable examples of socialist
policy working very well to finish it's
interesting if you compare someone like
Singapore to Venezuela if Singapore has
oil none of that happens right yeah you
do not let Lee corn you and a bunch of
really intelligent competent remarkable
young men run a country if they have a
shed load of hydrocarbons because we
have many examples where people try to
do that and they mostly got murdered
um Singapore's Advantage was it had no
natural resources and it was in the same
neighborhood as Vietnam and China so the
US was actually quite happy to sort of
say well look let them do their thing
um so it's a bit more complicated that
and I I don't want to be I hope I never
and sort of seen as an apologist but
um I I do think there are really
important lessons to learn from
um a whole range of societies and I
think I think there are positive lessons
to learn from you know quote unquote
conservative societies and think about
what works so let's look at the positive
lessons
from what would you implement left-wing
policies in this country that we do not
have to make Society fairer and better
for all what would you do left-wing
policies yes I think my first policies
wouldn't even be that left-winning but
um okay well what would be your policies
yeah that's the interesting thing
oh they wouldn't even be they wouldn't
even be left wing I think the very first
thing I'd do is I'd scrap police and
crime Commissioners I think we have far
too many non-jobs in this country yeah
political parties exactly I'm not trying
to be popular because I have such a bug
bear with uh police and crime
Commissioners I'd reduce the House of
Lords and I think there's arguments
about how it works do you have it
elected do you scrap it all together do
you keep it as it's presently composed
those arguments are quite strong I don't
necessarily agree with them but we can
have that debate as you say this isn't
the left-wing Point there's lots of
people on the right and in the center
would agree with that yeah but I think
it's definitely smaller right it's
pressing on 900 it should be like 400
tops
um I would have the number of counselors
but I'd pay councilors double what they
presently get because I don't think
people we don't really have tons of
people in local government because
they're not paid enough so I'd give them
twice responsibility and twice the pay
none of that's left wing but I think
that's like really low hanging fruit to
improve the country right then in terms
of um socialist policies so for instance
I think I think what Singapore does on
um on land is really good you know I
think I probably scrap council tax and
introduce and value tax because it's
fairer and land value tax is a few
things it incentivizes the productive
use of land so if you own land and
nothing's happening with it and you're
being taxed even if it's a small amount
of tax a year you shift it quite quickly
or if you've got an empty building in
central London it's put into use very
quickly so that would be my first thing
probably as a land value tax and get rid
of council tax which is incredibly
unfair why
what was it unfair yeah because it's not
about
um it's not about how much you earn so
for instance
um you might be living in a
really good example students.pat for
instance students don't pay council tax
and if you're in um Leeds or uh where I
live in Portsmouth you might be in a
council Ward where there are thousands
of students they still have the bins
collected they still have all manner of
services they can use
but they're not paying into it what
would be far better is if the landlord
was paying a land value tax and so
there's lots of there's lots of problems
with um with council tax again
pensioners tend not to pay it uh you can
get um various forms of relief and
whatnot I think a land value tax has
less bureaucracy less administration
because you don't have all these little
locked outs and I think I think it's
just fairer although I don't have any
issue with any of that but what about
seizing the means of production when
does that happen
um I wouldn't I wouldn't look I'm taking
the piss but I'm just curious because
none of that is like you you say you're
a Marxist but none of that is really a
Marxist thing yeah right so the so where
does the Marxism come in yeah so for
instance I would have um I would have a
national Development Bank I would have a
bank which is owned by the state
um which goes around really financing
businesses it's led by business people
right it's not just financing every time
they can Harry
but it's for instance looking to grow
businesses in underdeveloped areas
for ages like why don't why doesn't the
government buy a piece of land in the
center of London somewhere close to the
center and start something for people
like us where you get subsidized rent on
a space that is suitable for the the new
Tech Industries the New Media whatever
where you can rent a podcast Studio to
launch yourself and then once you've
done well you go off and you do it but
you pay beta yeah and incubator exactly
like I'm totally with that can we come
back to the kind of more like big idea
principle because you mentioned
something about workers having a bigger
share of the the productive
stuff that they create basically right
and I was curious about this and please
understand this is not a gotcha and I'll
please go for it so get the tweets out
I don't know what your situation is with
Navara but if you found it I imagine you
have a chunk of the equities
no is it is not a it's not a business or
so I'm not even a director you know what
[__] it then it doesn't matter because
I'm not trying to catch you out you can
no no but I don't want to I'm trying to
have a conversation so trigonometry
right
me Francis me and Francis started it
yeah right we owned 50 50. we also then
had someone come in and be our executive
producer he owns some of the equity of
it we owe it this is three other
socialists right well we we no we're
capacitors we knew that for him to be
fully invested in it and also for him to
accept a terribly low wage we could pay
him at the time yeah exploitative
exactly the exploitative which he was
paid at the time I mean we we owe
nothing at that time so we were happy
with it anyway my point is right we
created this we took all the
entrepreneurial entrepreneurial risk we
put our own money into it for years
without taking any money out of it right
we worked incredibly hard yes someone
who comes in now and contributes 30
pounds worth of work an hour should get
a significant chunk of that but what
about the fact that someone had to start
this and take all of the risk for the
worker to then come in and actually do
it because we don't really live in the
world that Marx was writing about where
all you needed was a loom in the factory
and then you get some bodies in there to
work it do you know what I mean no
you're entirely right it's a very
different world
um it's very different world to what it
was 50 60 years ago when our parents
were our age or you know a bit younger
um
it's a very fair point uh and as
somebody who's you know also co-founded
a media organization I I feel your pain
you know it's no pain it's your baby no
but I think you're right there's no pain
I'm very happy to pay people what I
think is a fair wage but it's not going
to look like what you think is a fair
way just my point well so let's say you
guys get a cleaner yeah and I don't know
what you you know I don't know what the
arrangement is for you guys you get a
cleaner
um I presume you would you know so you
wouldn't say let's give her a minimum
wage I I don't know what your values are
but if you're paid decent money and
you're and you're doing well and your
audience likes you I I genuinely think
it's a perfectly normal Humane response
to say yeah give the clean out a 15 16
quid an hour she does a great job the
place is clean we need we value a clean
we actually prepare cleaner more than
that there you go right so well here's
the thing and
not even a necessarily A criticism of
capitalism then right we're going to
something different things like
Outsourcing and that's actually how lots
of this country works today right and I
feel like sometimes we're having debates
at like the wrong level
serco
colas G4S Sodexo these companies are
disgusting they shouldn't exist because
what they do is they'll go into a
workplace let's say a hospital or
whatever or school and you know they
function on a similar-ish way to what
you we just sort of discussed somebody's
paid relatively well coalesce will go in
there and they say you know what they're
not they're paid too much we need to
reduce costs the whole point of
Outsourcing is screwing working people
over so
um there's a few layers here and I I
think frankly too much of the UK economy
looks like that right if people will
like yourselves starting businesses and
I think that's the natural human impulse
and Instinct they do a good job pay them
a fair wage right yeah but that isn't
where we are as a country that isn't
where we are right it's where we are
yeah that's where you are and my point
is I feel quite often the conversation
we have about these issues sort of fails
to take that Nuance into account now
this is not unusual for political debate
admittedly but they never take neurons
account look on all these big government
Outsourcing with these companies that
abuse people of I completely agree with
that and but so the other thing I don't
agree with them I agree with you yeah
I'm trying to say I guess the the one
point that someone would make is look
Aaron automation is coming in we're
seeing it we're seeing it with AI we're
seeing it with robots if you're going to
pay people a lot and you're saying to
them you know they deserve a fairer
chunk which emotionally and look my mum
first generation immigrant before the
minimum wage I think she was on like two
pound 30 an hour it was something like
that in the 90s she earned literally
nothing had no rights to a pension she's
disabled now entirely dependent on my
dad and with me helping them they scrape
by so I get what you're saying and
it resonates with me I guess we're
looking down the line at AI
Automation and you're going are we not
just going to make people
millions of jobs obsolete is that not
the danger here as well all right book
about it
fully automated luxury communism
um I I think and this is why uh you know
I use the c word yeah and this is why I
use the c word because I think and and
the trajectory here is 50 100 years
realistically we're looking at a
situation when
basically every human task can be
automated I think within 50 to 100 years
I think that's I think that's
quite likely right except podcast except
podcasts um and at which point like you
say that that creates that creates
massive dysfunctions in a bunch of ways
so for instance if you have um workers
who don't have cash Capital to buy goods
and services which are made more
productively than ever before bookshelf
so much automation then you have a
crisis of what's called under under the
price of demand or under consumption
which is you don't have people who can
buy all the goods and services being
made you have a problem another issue is
that the remaining jobs that are there
and which um are captured by uniquely
human sort of characteristics those are
paid better and better and better
because you can't automate Cristiano
Ronaldo or a great TV or podcasters you
can't automate those guys right for now
um and so what that means is that
automation compresses jobs like you know
we've seen it manufacturing for decades
but I think it's going to come for
driving in a decade or two and then
basically it's going to come for
everything and so I think as a society
we have a bunch of problems there like I
say price of demand and and if we think
inequality is bad now my God you know
it's going to be even worse than 30 40
50 years time and I would also add Aaron
a crisis a meaning because jobs group
jobs bring dignity and they bring an
identity and they bring and they bring
structure well that's why I use this and
that's why I use the c word because this
is a profound challenged capitalism it's
a profound challenge capitalism and I
think we need to be honest about that
because you know the economists did a
great line about this in 2013 they said
what happens when Capital becomes labor
which is to say there is no distinction
between capital and labor once you can
automate pretty much everything and that
we might not see it I think we probably
will our children will see it and and so
what's the sort of political economic
settlement when that happens you know I
it
doesn't look like capitalism it doesn't
look like capitalism as we know it so
that's why I use the c word no but
controversial the thing is I don't think
I I don't know about Francis I certainly
don't disagree that in a world where no
one has to work it sort of doesn't make
sense that the people who historically
have held the capital now own everything
and no one else has anything in a world
where no one needs to work and
everything's done by robots a system of
Distributing resources fairly equally in
that world is great actually I think I'm
sure there's counter arguments to that
that I probably haven't considered but
I'm open to that but what Francis was
asking was something else which is in
the interim because you know we're all
going to live in that interim 100 years
right there's quite a lot of human lives
in that when you when you raise wages
what you are doing is you're
incentivizing those jobs out of
existence yeah right and so isn't there
a counterproductive element to some of
those drives for higher wages in certain
industries yes there's a guy he just
died actually a guy called Mario tronte
he was a Marxist Italian uh sort of
thinker and he said exactly this so
historically people have always thought
Innovation is driven by capitalists
right you know yeah great levels of
automation new Innovations to create
things more productively he says no it's
created by workers and struggle them
struggling for better work better paying
conditions more money is the is the
Catalyst for better Innovation right
because that leads to like the things
you create incentives yeah you I mean
this is the literally like page one or
two of The Wealth of Nations right so I
think I think again even if you even if
you're not on the left if you want a
high productivity high performance
economy
there's the argument for higher wages
because you're going to create
incentives for businesses to
um increase productivity use more fixed
Capital hold on you care about the
working people you want to automate
their jobs out of existence no no but if
you look if you have if you have working
class representation you have Labor
organizations and the state is on their
side they can be reallocated to other
parts of the labor market they can be
retrained or you can say look the
evidence is very poor on people being
retrained no I agree with you well in an
aging population we probably will need
to retrain some people to to help you
know with regards to healthy care work
for instance I don't mean like uh
retrain design an app that's [__] I
agree with you there but on on things
like I think I mean really demographic
aging so I think in the US
over 50 of the sort of the the jobs
which are are growing significantly are
in relation to health and Elderly Care
Services because we're getting older as
a society we're having fewer babies and
people are living longer generally
speaking
um so I suppose the quick answer is in
the interim what do we do I think
there's a bunch of challenges in the
21st century that we need to uh take
head-on in to borrow a phrase from kirst
armor a mission-oriented sense I agree
with that
um I think one is demographic aging I
think another is the housing crisis and
I think a third is climate change now
people might be watching this going oh
climate change look at the weather
outside globally speaking it's a huge
Challenge and particularly for sort of
countries to our South they're going to
really struggle
um and I think you know we're going to
have to gear up to a world which looks
very different to today so those will be
what I say we need to use the dividend
of technological change to human genius
to address those challenges in the
interim because like you say full
automation is is decades away yeah I
wish we hadn't run out of time there
because I'd love to talk to you about
climate change but we're going to go to
locals where we'll continue the
conversation with questions from our
audience so people can follow us there
but before we do we always end with the
same question what's the one thing we're
not talking about as a society that we
really should be
I've just used my demographic aging card
um but you can talk about it let's talk
about it more just give us a brief yeah
headline of what you're talking about we
talk about climate change we talk about
a bunch of other crises I think for the
West over the next 50 years demographic
aging is the biggest problem because you
have people living longer
um you have uh the portion of the oldest
old people over 85 mushrooming good
that's a success story but they have
incredibly expensive care needs at the
same time the tax base the working age
population is comparatively shrinking
has so many challenges with regards to
growth with regards to what healthy
political culture looks like and how you
fund public services so this is the
thing which I I I think as a it's it's a
it's a terrifying challenge uh although
it comes from a very good place as
living longer and we generally don't
talk about it enough we need to do what
you and I are doing which is have more
babies
that's it yeah mine's on the way you
need to you need to do like Elon Musk
you know it's I mean there's different
ways of doing it seven or eight right
yeah yeah but I sort of feel like if
you're gonna have children you should
really be be there is how I feel yeah
and this isn't a guy Elon Musk this is a
go everyone yeah
Aaron bastani thank you so much for
coming on uh if you like Aaron's work
follow him at Novara media but join us
on locals for your questions and answers
[__] it we got time well not much but we
got some time climate change
[Music]